JENNY BROWN: In a
previous episode,
we talked about how
Critter Junction acquired
another company and
had to integrate
their VMs with their
existing architecture.
This had gone well so
far, but Critter Junction
had noticed some
areas where things
could be improved using
Google Cloud Persistent
Disks to save money and to make
the entire application more
scalable.
Stay tuned to see how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
After the big acquisition,
Critter Junction
had to maintain and, ideally,
upgrade another company's VMs.
After using the architecture
for a few months,
one of the first potential areas
of improvement Critter Junction
found was that there were
many of these VMs disks that
were being
underutilized, meaning
the speed at which the
application was requesting
data was much slower than
the speed their disk could
read the data.
And they realized that other
parts of the architecture
were overutilizing resources.
So Critter Junction
also realized
if their growth
projections were accurate,
they would need to
resize their VMs'
disks as they would very quickly
outgrow their current disk
size.
And on top of all that,
they wanted this resizing
to happen without any downtime
or costly VM restarts,
if possible.
This seemed like a lot to ask
for, but what they didn't know
is that Google Cloud
Persistent Disks
solve a lot of their problems.
Let's dig in.
Google Cloud
Persistent Disks are
a durable, high-performance
block-storage option
for Cloud VMs.
Their main benefit is that
they can be attached to
or detached from VMs as needed,
allowing for long-lived data
to persist even where
those VMs are started,
stopped, or terminated.
There are three different
types of block storage.
Local SSDs are
high-performance scratch spaces
that are best suited for
in-memory databases up
to 9 terabytes in size.
Then there's standard
persistent disks.
These are network devices
suited for large data-processing
workloads that primarily
use sequential IOs.
There are SSD
persistent disks, which
are suited for
enterprise applications
and high-performance
database needs that
require lower
latency and more IOPs
than standard persistent
disks provide.
SSD persistent
disks are designed
for single-digit-millisecond
latencies.
The observed latency
is app specific.
And finally, there are
balanced persistent disks
which, as named, provide
a balance between PD
standard and PD SSDs.
They are backed by a solid-state
drives that balance performance
and cost.
Now that we reviewed
the different types,
let's see how this applied
to Critter Junction.
Critter Junction mostly uses
standard persistent disks,
which are good for using as
boot devices, persisting data,
used as data-distribution
devices for static website
content, and they
can be a useful way
to replicate data across zones.
Unfortunately, the
current architecture
didn't take much advantage
of these features
because each PD is attached
to a corresponding VM.
As we mentioned, this
caused the application
to underutilized some PDs
while overutilizing others.
Another concern
Critter Junction had
is that as their application
data and boot volume grows,
they're afraid they'll have to
reboot the VM, detach the PD,
resize it, and reattach
it, resulting in scaling
limits with downtime.
Fortunately, this
isn't the case at all.
What Critter
Junction didn't know
is that persistent disks
provide scalability
because multiple VM
instances can connect
to content at the same time
within the same zone, allowing
applications to scale up
or instances down as needed
to serve data to customers.
And better yet, attaching
a persistent disk
to multiple virtual
machines doesn't
affect total performance
or cost either.
Each machine gets a share of
the per disk performance limit.
Performance scales
automatically with size,
so you can resize existing PDs
or add more PDs to an instance
to meet performance and
storage-space requirements.
Each PD can be up to
64 terabytes in size,
so there's no need to
manage arrays of disk
to create large logical volumes.
Critter Junction also didn't
realize that persistent disks
provide nearly
unlimited flexibility
by allowing you to resize
your storage while it's
in use by one or more virtual
machines with no downtime.
That means they could resize
their disks on the fly
without interruption.
This is all made possible
by Google Cloud Persistent
Disks being network attached.
Since the disks
aren't physically
attached to the VMs
that are using them,
you get the benefit of using
Google's network fabric, which
can deliver more than 1 petabit
per second of total bisection
bandwidth.
That's a lot of that.
With all of this
new information,
Critter Junction went
ahead and moved away
from assigning one PD per VM.
This allowed them to
connect more VM instances
to their underutilized disks.
These instances all read from
the same standard persistent
disk, allowing the
entire application
to serve more users.
And for the disks that
were overutilized,
Critter Junction decided to
upgrade them to larger disks.
And best of all,
Critter Junction
took advantage of Google Cloud
Persistent Disks' ability
to resize a storage
while it's in use by a VM
to do all of this
without any downtime.
For Critter Junction, Google
Cloud Persistent Disks
turn out to be a simple,
fast, and flexible solution
for those needs.
So that's a wrap for this
episode of "Season of Scale."
Stay tuned for more
about Critter Junction.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]